hey everyone its era thread sterner
sorry and calm and today I'm going to
show you how to break open a glass
ampule so you'll want to confirm that
you have the right medication and it's
the right dose you're giving it at the
right time via the right route to the
right patient then you'll want to
perform hand hygiene and gather your
supplies you want to get your ampule
that contains the medication you want to
get an alcohol prep pad and some gauze
then you want to inspect the ampule make
sure it's not cracked anywhere the
fluids not discolored or it has
particles floating in it then you want
to get all the liquid medication down
there in the body of the ampule because
sometimes it likes to collect here in
the head and the neck
so to get it down into the body what you
want to do is just gently tap it and it
will all go down into the body of the
ampule then we want to take our alcohol
prep pad and we're going to clean the
neck of the ampule just to decrease
contamination when we actually go to
break it and we're going to let it dry
completely
once the ampule is dry we are ready to
break it so we're going to take our
cause and we're going to hold our ampule
on a flat sturdy surface and sort of
steady it and we're going to wrap the
gauze around the head in the neck of the
ampule like this and then when we go to
break it we're going to break it in this
motion like a snapping motion so
whatever actually breaks the broken
parts are away from our body so we don't
get cut so take that gauze hold it
around the head the neck and just snap
it off then you're going to take this
part of the head of the ampule and
you're going to dispose of that in the
sharps so you don't cut yourself along
with the gauze thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos